moments ago
tim tobacco asked folks to stand for a
moment of silence
in honor of the late renee stennett
passed away this past week the age of 72
after a battle with cancer
one of the great pirates certainly some
butterflies i would think for cody ponce
even though this isn't his first big
league start
there are fans in the stands unlike last
year absolutely i'm looking forward to
watching cody throw today
so judy allen here is baez
that's laced into left field and that'll
fall for a base hit as gamble collects
and so javi
with a two out knock here's anthony
rizzo and a swing and a ground ball
softly hit on to short
big friendly hop for tucker on the first
for the out inning is through
nothing big against cody ponce is the
two out single jake garrieta on the
mound
for the chicago cubs and he's pitched
twice against the pirates this year and
pitched well both times
right away the hitz machine
and the major's hits leader singles to
center field
62nd hit of the season he's quickly
aboard for ben gamel
and a line drive base head into right
field frazier
to third gamel not slowing down
into second a double pirates in business
second and third and nobody out for
reynolds goes to the backstop
karen's up the first baseline everyone's
able to advance
and the pirates lead one nothing on a
very wild pitch
yes it is there's that communication
there looks like it might have been a
cross up not for sure
and so with one out still a chance for a
deep fly ball to score
gamal here's jacob stallings and that
takes care of that
stallings makes certain the pirates will
cash in that second run
two-nothing once again he got
got away with that fastball out over the
plate he just doesn't have command of it
tonight and the pirates have taken
advantage of it cody potts back out
working with a two-nothing lead
ian happ will lead it off that's a base
hit and
gonna have to hustle to keep him at
first
nicely done by the veteran gamble boy he
really sprinted over there and holds
half to a single
put a circle around that that could be
huge so one out men at the corners
and the number eight hitting pj higgins
swinging the ground ball to third on to
second there's one
relay two a double play they go around
the horn
five four three that equals two
and the cubs get none we'll go to the
bottom of the second
two aboard against jake arrieta with two
outs campbell doubled back in the first
inning and a swinging aligner off the
middle base hit
craig around third he's going to try to
score
and he will on the base hit by gamel
and the pirates lead three to nothing a
great job of hitting again another
missed spot to ball out over the plate
gamble took advantage of that throw the
baseball right back up the middle and
they still got a chance here with the
reynolds up
swinging a miss strike three he has
struck out
reynolds twice we go to the third one
down third inning here's jock peterson
let's see if the second time through the
lineup for the cubs offense can
start doing some damage against ponce
that one hit
in the air right field that one way back
and that one is gone jack peterson over
the high wall
in right field will touch them all and
the cubs are on the board
over the 21-foot wall in right
and for jack it's his third of the year
we knew it was just a matter of time the
contact
since coming off the il had been really
good he's hitting the ball hard he just
wasn't hitting it with a lot of loft
dubs get on the board trail three to one
and here's chris bryant
and nice work pots right up the ladder
with him
his first punch out of the night we go
to the fourth ian happ will start things
and a swing and a miss and the throw
down to first base to complete the
strikeout so hap
is gone and cody ponce kind of pitching
like he's been around for a while
yeah it's good to see cody out again
just confident conviction in every pitch
david bode horner with three steals
leads from first the pitch
swinging the ground ball on to short
tucker on the second one relay
two another double play the pirates have
issued a couple of double plays behind
cody ponce tonight
we'll go to the bottom of the fourth and
here is cole tucker leading off
for the bucks against jake arrieta
outside corner ring them up and jake
garrieta
with the strikeout first five swinging
now he
throws this back door cutter right over
the outside edge at the bottom of the
knees
area now settling down he sat down six
in a row
now the pitcher ponce hits a big bouncer
to horner from the edge of the outfield
grass throws out punts
and that's a one two three inning we go
to the fence and one-on-one base runner
in front of peterson who homebrewed his
last time up
that one hit in the air right field that
one
going back and it's gone he's done it
again
you go mr mustache a two-run homer and
we are tied
it is three apiece big smiles
jack peterson his fourth a line drive
over that right center field fence
with the go ahead run on second base in
baez and two away that'll bring up the
cleanup man anthony rizzo
rizzo swings and taps one up the middle
and through for a base hit
rounding third and coming home is baez
and the cubs take the lead
on the rbi single by anthony rizzo
four to three cubs over the pirates here
in the fifth adam frazier's gonna lead
it off for the pirates
got him swinging jake arrieta locked in
after a bumpy beginning
arietta has now set down eight in a row
man
on second base that's the tying run with
two outs in reynolds stallings at the
plate
stallings grounds one left side
backhanded by bodhi
toss across the body in time to get
stallings a difficult play
but the cubs get out of the gym through
five
nicole horner first up against the new
pitcher clay
holmes punts it towards third pretty
good one holmes up with it
unloads out at first and then nico takes
a tumble
is he okay nope no that looks like a
hamstring
yeah that i mean that hurt because you
could you're just looking at his
face the discomfort david ross out there
along with the medical people he's
walking off we'll go to the seventh
inning now it's 4-3 chicago
and the cubs are in business first and
second and one out and it's baez at the
plate
right in there strike three call 98 over
the outer edge
bednar strikes out baez so two down
and anthony rizzo will come up to hit
it's weakly popped up towards center
reynolds coming on
he makes the catch bednar strands two
runners
and keeps this a one-run affair pirates
have the tying run
90 feet away the go-ahead run at second
with two down here in the seventh inning
and the switch hitting
brian reynolds one of their very best
hitters is at the plate
check swing did he go yes he did strike
three and the inning is going to come to
an end
chaffin strikes out reynolds he chased a
third pitch
out of the strike zone down low we go to
the ninth inning tucker 0 for two
lifetime against kimbrell
and lines it into right center field
headed toward the wall at least two
tucker gonna turn it on and head to
third no he's gonna put on the brakes
and as it turns out that was a wise move
a double
for cole tucker on craig kimbrell to
start the bottom of the night tucker
runs well he's at third with one out for
iodimaro vargas
swing and a miss he struck him out
so he gets the strikeout and now with
tucker at third it comes down to this
a runner at third and adam frazier
coming to the plate
that's a ground ball right to ballet
gathers it up
throws the first ball game comes win
and the bullpen continues to be
outstanding the cubs
with 25 wins on the season and
10 of them by one run amazing